I can't believe we're doing this but we
have to remember the Access Hollywood
grab him by the you-know-what tapes of
Donald Trump that set off that firestorm
the recording ended up getting Billy
Bush fired from television but it didn't
stop Donald Trump from becoming
president of the United States which is
weird and you'll remember that Trump
admitted that it was him on the tapes
right Trump admitted it was him he
apologized for what he described as
locker room talk on the tape and
generally you don't apologize for
something you never did now Donald Trump
is questioning whether the tapes are
actually authentic or whether they've
been doctored we learned over the
Thanksgiving holiday that earlier this
year Donald Trump told a u.s. senator
that the Access Hollywood tapes might
not be authentic he recently repeated
the exact same claim to an advisor and
Access Hollywood understandably had to
respond and say no no the tape is
completely real they said on a recent
broadcast let us make this perfectly
clear the tape is very real remember his
excuse at the time was locker room talk
he said every one of those words I want
to remind you again Trump already
admitted that it's his voice on the
tapes and apologized for what he said
how do you go from apologizing for it to
say there was never anything real to
apologize for in the first place here's
just a little bit of that apology that
Donald Trump issued I've said and done
things I regret
and the words released today on this
more than a decade old video are one of
them right anyone who knows me knows
these words don't reflect Who I am I
said it I was wrong and I apologize wow
I've traveled the country talking about
change for America that's pretty
definitive I said it I was wrong and I
apologize that apology was over
something fake that never happened now
there are a couple reasons why Trump
might do this the easiest and the
simplest is he's completely narcissistic
and thinks that maybe it's been long
enough that somebody might start to
believe him that hey
the tapes were doctored the second
option is that it's part of this four
dimensional chess that Trump plays meant
to distract from something else or
create media mayhem who knows that's
another possibility I would question
whether Trump even can play regular
chess but never mind 4d chess a third
option which is similar to the 4d chess
option but but not quite as refined is
that Trump has learned that there could
be even worse stuff coming out at some
point in the future and that he's laying
the groundwork to question the
authenticity of all of it and I don't
know what those recordings might be we
did hear before the election about Tom
Arnold said he had some recordings
related to the apprentice when Donald
Trump was on the apprentice and that
supposedly the stuff he did behind the
scenes that The Apprentice blows out of
the water the Access Hollywood tapes we
never heard more about that it's a
possibility that Trump is laying the
groundwork and kind of preemptively
playing defense for when those comes out
those come out and that really gets us
to the actual tragedy in this which is
and it pains me to say this it really
does some of Trump supporters are gonna
eat this up and believe it 110 percent
there is a group of Trump supporters
that has such cognitive dissonance when
it comes to Trump the hero versus Trump
the serial sexual assault er that they
will hear Donald Trump question the
authenticity of a tape that he's now not
only acknowledged the truth of but also
apologized for and they will start to
repeat it and say hey Trump said it the
tape is fake and those are the people
Pat that will never abandon the guy and
we need to forget about them when we
think about winning elections in the
future well I mean how many times has
Trump contradicted himself and how many
times has he peddled conspiracy theories
and it's just putting those two things
together
absolutely so that is the most
disturbing part of it that even though
it is so transparent so pathetically
bogus what Donald Trump is saying here
that the tapes might not be authentic it
has always worked it has always worked
for Trump and it will continue to work
for Donald Trump and that's why we need
to go around trumpets to win elections
in the United States special
actions in 2017 midterms in 2018 and the
general election in 2020 discuss this
with us on our reddit discussion forum
many of you are nearly 5,000 of you now
on our reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash re d di t today's
program is made possible in part by
blueSky binary have you heard of
blockchain blockchains the new trend in
technology and on the internet and too
many people are not aware of both the
power and the risks of blockchain
technology some people think it's too
complicated it's too difficult to get
into so people stay away and they miss
out on the opportunity to really know
about the opportunities that blockchain
presents but it doesn't have to be this
way and the solution is the blue sky
binary blockchain academy blue sky
binary is a leading financial education
and technology company and they're
turning their attention to blockchain
they've launched their blockchain
academy to complement their other
successful training programs and they've
created a blockchain education course
for beginners and active crypto users
alike and in this score course students
will be taken through a series of topics
which ultimately will deliver a solid
understanding of how blockchain works
and help the student realize the current
and potential future uses of block tank
blockchain technology we've talked about
some of these on the bonus show and on
the program and the course includes
video on-demand online tests access to a
community of traders and blockchain
enthusiasts who exchange knowledge and
experiences and you can register now to
get a 3 day free trial that includes
access to the first module of the course
for you to evaluate the overall quality
of the program and afterwards it's 49
and 99 a month you can stop and resume
at any point checkout blue sky
binary.com
slash david to sign up today